[Music]
so the king yeah we right back at it
baby you know what it is
it's that time now and I told you guys
this is where the boxing starts to heat
up now we have two main events tonight
on two competing networks and it goes
deeper than that we got two fights
within a fight
yeah Bob Arum versus al Heyman yeah
pay-per-view versus free you have
conglomerates versus conglomerates but
best of all baby you got these fighters
versus each other the walther weight
division is heating up at a feverish
pace
you got fighters that he's my best
fighters fighting tonight I mean the
only way I can't get any better if I had
Earl Spence fighting so let me give you
the top college this is in no particular
order so we got Danny Garcia versus
Adrian ganado
nice fight you for the PVC and that's on
Fox free tonight then we have bud
Crawford versus Amir Khan Wow
and that's on ESPN pay-per-view now
tonight if you'll fight kind of saw like
myself you're gonna have two screens
going watching both fights at the same
time because they're gonna be on at the
same time this is get on a lay downtown
this is pick your poison time this is
who do you really love time tonight is
own so let's do this in respectful
fashion all right so we're gonna go with
the PBC first and the reason why I'm
going with the PBC first is because ESPN
has an undefeated fighter and i'ma show
him respect
and let him walk in the ring as a
champion he is and also the PBC card
doesn't have a champion on it so but our
further ado let's get into this blonde
burner
Danny Garcia versus Adrian granado's now
a lot of people looking at this fight
like why well this is Danny Garcia
getting back to where he's supposed to
be this is Adrian Grenier rose trying to
step in here mess things up a lot of
people may look on the surface to see
all aging granado's you know this is
this is a gimme for Danny Danny Jenny's
gonna walk through this let's go give me
he's in fights boy you know that go
outside you think you're gonna win a
fight you just off your game over phone
you look at you look at you now so let's
check this out let's dissect this fight
how does this match up look good well it
looks fantastic to me because you have a
natural boxer puncher counter puncher
and Danny Garcia you have a come forward
relentless fighter and Ageing granado's
he can box and he can fight box and IQ
in this I'm gonna have to go Danny a
little bit more so Danny's boxing IQ is
an 8 say Adrian granado's is a 6 if you
want to say toughness both guys are
equal and toughness if you want to say
punching power you're gonna have to go
with Daniel if you're gonna go with
boxing technique you're gonna have to go
with then if you're gonna have to go
with footwork I'm gonna tell you i'ma go
with Adrian ganado you're gonna have to
go with speed now this is where it gets
tricky Danny's not a fast puncher
he's a timing puncher timing punchers
are the most dangerous punches in the
game they time you they wait they are
patient if you don't mix it up with
these type of fighters they catch you
boom flat out drop you you never see the
punch come
because they timed you that's why you
always got to mix it up
Adrienne ganado says to come forward
type of fighter he doesn't vary in speed
it's really one speed he has that's
where his problems lie and that's where
he will get in trouble with Danny I'll
see you tonight
Danny notoriously starts off slow see
I'm not gonna do like everybody does and
say Oh after those two losses that he
had one two Shawn Porter
I wanna keep Thurman that Danny Garcia
needs to switch things up know what
Danny Garcia needs to do and the level
of frustration because of his coach
because of his trainers because of his
fans as he starts slow Danny Garcia
needs to start off a little bit faster
in order to win a fight of these
magnitudes
now he's back at midpoint he's fighting
a mid-level boss and Adrian ganado
so Adrian Ganados is gonna come forward
he's gonna be a little bit more busier
than Danny in the first couple of rounds
as Danny gets his timing down he's gonna
start moving a Ginga Nardo's to the
ropes he's gonna start banging him to
the body and throwing that left hook
there's gonna be a blind overhand right
that he throws from the hip down I
believe he stops Adrian Ganados
somewhere between the ninth and tenth
round because I respect a drinking
otto's that much and he's gonna last
that long and take that much punishment
he's gonna give a goal there's gonna be
one hell of a fight now on the talents
bud Crawford versus a mere King Kong on
ESPN pay-per-view
I know y'all like ESPN pay-per-view when
that became a thing now I haven't had a
pay-per-view in 14 years and this is it
see bud been protected pretty much all
of his career yeah they pretty much they
put them in there with guys that might
say Gamboa
gambol was 32 years old he was 26 years
old he had 74 inch reach Gamboa had a 63
inch reach Gamboa was a shark a short
leap in type of fighter and he has
important I think it was like what it
was 24 months so he was force-fed Bud
Crawford he had a lot of term only took
the fight only because he had financial
difficulties the fact I suppose for him
a couple of times because
Gamboa had to lose weight because he
wasn't training properly I only say that
to say this that but this fight is
really your fight this is the fight of
your life right now a man King Kong was
on the top of his his heap before Danny
took him out man King Kong was that dude
at 17 years old I remember I told you
guys watch out for Olympians he's a
two-time Olympian he lost one year in
Olympics that a silver medal for Great
Britain decided to come back again
finished out silver cuz he wanted to
beat the guy that beat him talk about
hot at 17 years old this boy was a
phenom beaten grown men you know how
with pure speed and boxing ability on
tonight's card this is probably the best
boxer purest boxer Amir Khan was that
dude but he's a holdover from a
generations past can he used a muscle
memory to get back to where he needs to
be
can he sum it all up for one fight
tonight can he hold that pride to get it
in bud Crawford boy you can't say too
many good things about bud
bud is a switch hitter he can fight
Orthodox to southpaw
that means lead left right hand orally I
mean lead left hand or lead right hand
[Music]
but can box he can punch he can move
always comes in shape and he has a
mindset of a fighter dog Britt bite down
you hit me I'll hit you you talk mess
what but I think they do you really want
to pick a fight way but again you're
saying King while you pick this fight to
make me be upset
Amir Khan boxing skill out of all the
fighters tonight his hiya Amir Khan
if he fights tall can box that is awful
bud Crawford now this is where this
fight differs from the first fight you
see where you had a natural counter
puncher versus our ongoing offensive
fighter that made for spectacular
television here you have to come forward
fighters now this is the difference
between bud and Amir Khan from the
get-go Aamir Khan is always ready to go
his fastball special was nuts
hit throw that one one and hit youth the
two and follow with two three that's a
double jab right hand left hook might
finish it off to the body like he did
Mike Donna
he hit Maidana under the rib short rib I
think in the first round and had Maidana
rolling around on the floor like here I
got gunshot you're hurt
boy look like he had a gunshot wound
upon him this is the part where bud has
to be wary you may not see that blind
right hand you may not see the step-over
left hook you may not be ready you
really think you fought all it needs to
be
you know for this is a two-time Olympian
here and I've seen nothing but
disrespect on your part
maybe it's confidence he's supposed to
have confidence everybody's supposed to
have confidence but I think is
dismissive I think you looked at the
fact that he went up and waiting for
Canelo Amir Khan for Canelo and got laid
out but you didn't look at the fact that
he was beating the brakes off Genoa all
the way up until the knockout and this
is what happens with Amir Khan Aamir
Khan has lapses in judgment while he's
fighting he fights he fights he fights
and then he loses perspective because
most of the time he's up he gets bored
he drops his left hand
that's when sneaky right overhand rights
coming he leaves his head up too high he
pulls straight out after a combination
these things infuriate trainers because
these are the things that they try to
cover up while you're training these
things are innate in the boxer and
cannot be wiped out so now you got bud
going into this fight I believe
overconfident I believe really not
understanding who the hell he's facing
tonight he's facing that dude and you
know bud feels like he's that dude he
feels that the only thing that you know
can stop arrow sprint strain is him boy
you getting that ring with arrows
sprints and I'm saying it right now
arrows Spence will clean yo damn clock
he's bigger stronger timing and more
malicious better stay in your lane but
you're a great fighter but else Spence
is the truth ie his name the truth back
to you bud bud is gonna try to establish
his jab his jab is not gonna be nowhere
near mare Khan's jab Amir Khan will keep
that jab going all night if anything
else backing up throwing that jab but
that's what it is but has to back him up
to be effective
bud has to shoot the right hand over the
top we all know Americana chinna's and
all that but I take that and chalk that
up to lack of focus lack of perspective
when it matters so now why do I pick it
up and feel like you might have a
12-round split decision
well bud Crawford losing because I think
American pulls it together tonight I
think American just says you know what
this is it it ain't no more he's the
last dude in the bar right now they bout
to turn the lights out on them can it
happen
hell yeah can happen so one of them
charlo boys lose right off of a fighter
that he took too lightly
boxing is a hell of a game you're not on
point every night your opponent might
become Buster Douglas
remember what Buster Douglas did to Mike
Tyson right when he took him to light
cautionary tale bud respect every
fighter especially them Olympians they
stone-cold dangerous watch ILP tomorrow
1:00 p.m. standard Eastern Time are you
gonna have me go through the fight
results I honestly hope that I'm wrong
but honestly Holkar don't get you but
you know how I can call him dude come
running through your city tearing things
up me Kathleen man con 12-round
split-decision Danny Garcia knockout
ninth to tenth friend ninth attempt
around fight one hell of a fight when is
you will me baby you know what it is
it's combat talk with
King TuneIn IOP tamal get the real
[Music]